and you know what what the sad part is
there's also about 120 billion dollars a
year spent on security services software
and hardware
and that doesn't it helps but it doesn't
stop the issue right you still hear
about attacks every single day of the
week you know we deal with ransomware on
a daily basis you've heard you've
probably heard about colonial pipeline
the big cyber attack a few weeks ago
that left the southeast of the united
states without fuel you know uh you know
few gas stations had like riots going on
it was crazy and that was a cyber attack
okay so this is the world we're leaving
it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders we're
talking about the cyber security space
but from a different angle this time
from the insurance angle and digital
risk this is going to be a great one
meet roman itzkevich founder and chief
risk officer at adbay
roman is the co-founder and chief risk
officer of adbay a cyber insurer digital
risk is complex and constantly evolving
with breaches in the news all the time
driving trillions of annual losses to
society at bay helps businesses prevent
cyber loss before it happens and insure
them for when the loss couldn't be
avoided their modern approach to risk
management has kept at bay ahead of the
pack anticipating new threats and
identifying vulnerabilities to help keep
insurers secured
roman izkovic welcome to 20 minute
leaders at bay how are you
i'm good thank you and thanks for having
me this is going to be fun thank you
this is going to be a lot of fun over
these 20 minutes
i love the industry that you and i love
it when people come and are disrupting
an age-old industry from the bottom up
rethinking through technology how we
should be interacting with the industry
you're the founder and cro of at bay but
previously you've done an incredible
incredible amount of things from
mckinsey to bain to iberi to harvard
business school at tel aviv university
so really it's extraordinary journey and
and what i'm curious to start with is i
want you to explain to me what what are
you doing at adbay what's what problem
are you solving and then what i want to
do is i want to understand how does your
journey throughout all these amazing
companies how how did it help you
understand that this is a problem worth
solving and the right way to solve it
okay sounds great so let's start with
adbay and edbay is a cyber insurer so
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to provide companies with security
against cyber attacks and you know to
understand why this is needed i think we
need to go a step a step back right uh
so
you know one of my highlights of my
career at that bay was telling mark
andreessen from recent horowitz that
cyber risk is eating the world because
it's coming on the back of software
eating the world
and i really believe that's true you
know every business is a technology
business every industry now uses more
and more technology in their day-to-day
operations which means that
the risk to your technology right now is
the main risk to your business you know
companies are more worried about cyber
attacks than they are about you know
burglary or earthquakes or fires or
whatever it is right and look there's
about a trillion dollars every year lost
because of cyber crime
one trillion dollars and you know wow
i thought it's in a few years i didn't
realize it was already here yeah no it's
it's there and you know what but the sad
part is there's also about 120 billion
dollars a year spent on security
services software and hardware
and that doesn't it helps but it doesn't
stop the issue right you still hear
about attacks every single day of the
week you know we deal with ransomware on
a daily basis you've heard you've
probably heard about colonial pipeline
the big cyber attack a few weeks ago
that left the southeast of the united
states without fuel you know uh you know
a few gas stations had like riots going
on it was crazy and that was a cyber
attack okay so this is the world we're
living in and because technology can't
fully solve cyber risk we think we need
to approach it as any other financial
risk you know technology doesn't solve
earthquakes as well and that's why you
have insurance
uh so
so you know so the premise is okay how
do we help with insurance and then we
asked ourselves uh you know can
traditional insurance deal with it and
the answer for us was
no and look there are two components
here okay
uh which are which are required and i
think we should be dealt with separately
one component is
you know
how does cyber risk behave and how do
you tackle it and i would argue that
it's a lot more technical you need to go
into the data you need to collect
information you need cyber analysts you
don't need actuaries uh or you need
cyber analysts in addition to actuaries
we have both by the way
uh to deal with this and traditional
insurance has a very hard time the
second issue with cyber risk is that
it's incredibly dynamic you know i'll
give you an example i like to give
reinsurers when i talk to them you know
fire is a static risk fire burns wood
faster than stone and it was true 500
years ago it's true today it's most
likely going to be true in 100 years so
when you insure a house against fire you
know that the stone house is going to be
more secure than a wooden house full
stop
we don't have this privilege with cyber
you know when we underwrite a company
and we look at their technology stack
today it might look great but tomorrow
there might
be a new attack a new threat or they
might change their technology stack
because suddenly they need to move to
the cloud or they need to start working
remotely like many companies needed to
do during covet and it's a very it
becomes a very bad risk the company is
at risk right your traditional insurance
model when you meet your client once a
year for renewal or twice a year if they
have a claim is just not good enough
this risk is way too dynamic so if you
really want to help companies you need
to be able to be very responsive on top
of it and help them not only with
coverage when they have an event but
also try to help them understand
when they're susceptible to attack and
how to deal with it and i'll give you
another example from traditional
insurance you know let's take hurricanes
for example okay
so
we know a hurricane is coming a few days
ahead of the hurricane heating right and
we also know the path waterless so if i
were a property insurer imagine how cool
it would be if i could tell everyone in
a certain zip code on the path of a
hurricane you know what guys
move your houses from florida to texas
for just three days you know and three
days go back and everything's gonna be
fine and you're not at risk anymore you
know that that's science fiction in
traditional insurance that's exactly
what we do with cyber because many times
the vulnerabilities are things that if
you know where to look and what to do
are pretty easy to overcome so so this
is where cyber is okay and the other
part is the infrastructure so you know
in order to be as dynamic and responsive
you need to use technology you can't you
can't be manually processing data
if you want to to adjust to what the
attackers are doing and just to give you
an example you know we aim for a insight
to implementation cycle of two weeks so
from knowing there's a new attack and
until our portfolio is is safe and our
all our underwriting and
pricing models are updated as a two-week
cycle for us that's our aim you know in
traditional insurance that's 18 months
okay
you can and the problem with traditional
insurance is they have a lot of legacy
software which means that if you want to
shorten those 18 months to 10 months you
need to spend hundreds of millions of
dollars and in numerable years and even
then you'll find yourself with new
legacy systems so i think that that's
kind of the second part of what we're
doing that is really cool and that is
because the risk is so dynamic you now
need a new infrastructure to be able to
deal with it and that's like super cool
and that's where you know that's the
part of our business that is similar to
other insure techs that you probably
know that invest in technology and user
flows and data to be able to be
responsive to their customers
so so i does that mean that adbay has to
be a cyber expert
in its own entity right to be able to
both identify the vulnerability not just
not just reading about it and
understanding it but then also trying to
really
piece together how does our how is our
portfolio going to be affected by this
yeah so um we at bay have a cyber
research team we have threat
intelligence we have data engineers we
have folks who were in military
intelligence running offensive cyber
projects because the best way to know
where attackers are coming is to think
like an attacker and then you know again
what i like to tell richards is that we
do all the same things an attacker would
do in the first uh step of an attack
project which is reconnaissance it's
just with us it doesn't end with a
breach it ends with a price you know
it's different it's a different ending
to a very similar mindset and work that
we're doing
now going going back to your journey how
you know the the insights that you have
here are are fantastic and i think that
right now also we're getting to
understand this but you've had these
insights for quite some time what what
led to those insights so what what in
the journey that you've done as a
learner and as an entrepreneur enabled
you to come up with these realizations
look so first of all uh i need to be
completely honest with you look we are
two founders today uh me and rotten my
co-founder rotten is the
i'm the finance guy okay so
and
you know my background if you look at
what i've done i've done a lot of
different flavors of finance i've done
investing with being capital
i've done online lending with ibry
which is a very similar mindset of how
do you take risk in an online flow use
data to make decisions and try to
optimise for like the flu the journey
but also the loss ratio and growth
right but so i'm coming at it from a
very financial viewpoint and you know
and and so cyber i had to learn over the
last few years from you know brought
them and from the teams we've built and
but what's exciting for me about this is
that you know if you think about it as a
security problem
only your the way you can react it
becomes very constrained right and what
i liked about it is like the
cross-functional view of i think about
it as a financial problem i think about
it as how do i minimize loss in my
portfolio and how do i minimize loss for
our insurance and i think about it in
dollars
and you know that's kind of my
background and i think that that's new
that's a perspective that only insurance
can give you and that's why i think
insurance has a very strong uh
part to play in cyber security as an
industry as a whole and then protecting
businesses against cyber attacks so so
my my learning you know if you will i
started with you know and just just to
be completely happy with you when we
started i knew my co-founder wrote them
from way way back before we started this
uh and at some point we said okay we
should do something together you know i
was doing lending he was doing uh
incident response work for like a he
built instant response teams on the
cyber side and then he had an insight
that you know insurance is the way to
solve this but
insurance companies he tried to to work
with the ig to help them figure this
stuff out and it just didn't work and we
were like well i'm a fintech guy he's a
cyber guy what do you do together well
you do cyber insurance because that's
like exactly the middle ground so that's
kind of how this company started
uh amazing
and look but i think that the the core
jesus hasn't changed and the court jesus
is that you know software is becoming
more and more important for business
operations across the board and the
risks to software are also becoming more
important on the back of it so you kind
of need to manage that that tension and
that's what we're that's what we're what
what nba is about
so what what have you learned
you know while we're while you know
running adbay from the way that others
other businesses are are understanding
the cyber risks and are and are willing
to even pay a premium to to get a
coverage on this because this is
something that is really non-trivial
it's something that pretty much didn't
people didn't even think of 20 years ago
yeah look i mean
um so when we started um
cyber cyber insurance had very low
penetration so not a lot of companies
bought it and typically only the
companies were most aware like you know
healthcare providers finance
banks that kind of stuff
and now everyone understands and you
know
the the thing that is amazing is that
how short-term
the thinking is in the market where
you know as a company like three years
ago it was hard to convince folks to buy
cyber insurance because they were like
well yeah we've heard about the target
bridge or the anthem bridge and all the
news but those are very large companies
no one is going after us you know mid
market on small companies like who cares
about john the manufacturing of which
widget from uh from michigan uh but
attackers care and you know and once you
see see more activity folks are suddenly
a lot more sensitive to cyber
uh to cyber the other thing i would want
to say that you know that i've developed
over the last few years is a deep
empathy for those businesses look you
know
they you know cyber is not their core
capability they don't know what it is
just like they don't know how to write
code to use the email or office like
they don't care and and if you don't
know how to code uh your you know word
to create word you can still use word
and there's no like catastrophic risk to
your business directly from that but if
you don't understand cyber and you're
not aware of that you know your business
could end you can end up in bankruptcy
because of one attack uh you know that's
something that i don't know that any
other financial risk to businesses has
as much impact uh these days so one i
think 100
now how does this impact your go to
market because i'm trying to imagine you
know the first few phone calls to
businesses that don't necessarily think
that they're that they'll be susceptible
to attacks because they may not be you
know they haven't seen other attacks so
how do you how do you position yourself
as a chief revenue officer thinking
through a go-to market strategy on this
so uh i'll make small correction i'm the
chief risk professor
officer sorry about that my uh my day
today is actually figuring out how do we
keep folks safe and as profitable but i
can i can talk to go to market uh and on
the go to market side
you know so
in commercial insurance in the us is by
and large sold through brokers and
and i think that that's here to stay
and the reason i say that is because
once you clear the very small end of the
market like the micro smb end of the
market
larger companies
don't understand like you have it's a
very technical buy you need to
understand the insurance right so you
kind of almost need a lawyer to help you
understand what's covered what's not
otherwise
especially in cyber where the coverage
has changed a lot and there's a lot of
new stuff going on and there's a lot of
garcia type of policies out there and
the risk itself is very technical so
even answering the question of how much
limits do i need to buy like what is a
big event for me as a business is a big
question that a lot of businesses have
no idea so so that's so we think that
brokers is the right path for this type
of coverage it is more sophisticated
than your standard coverages
and you know our issue has been over the
last year or so not how do you find
businesses and convince them for fine
brokers and convince them to work with
you our issue has been to actually
keeping up with the demand we have uh
that is coming from the market you know
because now people are really realizing
that going bare that's the insurance
lingual for without coverage is is
really scary especially on cyber uh so
so you know so we have the opposite
problem it's like how do we make sure
that we underwrite businesses well how
do we make sure that we have enough
resources to make sure that our
portfolio is safe even you know keeping
up with our growth which has been super
fast because of this
wow and so what's the next layer where
are we headed as a either as a society
or an ecosystem when it comes to
and to businesses dealing with potential
cyber attacks
that's a very good question um look
here's how i think about it you know
let's say you are a pizza shop in new
york and suddenly you know a chinese
tank shows up on the street and and aims
their gun at you right you would not be
expected to protect your business as the
business owner from that yeah right you
have the u.s military you have the coast
guard you have the new york police
department all those people
people's job is to protect you from that
harm right but when it comes to cyber
attack you might have international like
nation states going after you a small
business in the middle of uh of the us
and you're expected to protect yourself
not only are you expect expected to
protect yourself the government will
fine you if you don't do a good job and
you know they get access to customers
and i think that that's deeply unfair
okay and not only do i think it's deeply
unfair i also think that you know
insurance playing the only protection
role in there is also unfair and i don't
think that that's a sustainable position
i think that you know i would expect
governments to start protecting you know
businesses that are operating within the
country against those international
attacks so i think that you know the
discussion or whatever i've read about
the discussion between biden and putin
about cyber attacks was on point and i
think that that will escalate and i
think that over time governments will
take a deeper and deeper role in this
and i do want to say that you know going
back to the colonial pipeline attack
one of the things that these are most
amazing about that attack is that
kodian pipeline had a ransomware attack
they stopped operations they couldn't
supply gas to a bunch of the us and then
they paid ransom about four million
dollars in bitcoin to
uh get their systems back and then a few
days later i've read that the fbi i
think
went and closed back most of that ransom
money from the bitcoin wallets of the
attackers
and that's a first
uh but that's also how you know
governments typically deal with
organized crime they go after the funds
because if you make the business very
unprofitable
you kind of close the incentive and i
think that that's a first you know i
would expect to see more of that uh and
i'm actually surprised that more of that
haven't happened before that because
the colonic pipeline is by far not the
biggest ransom ever paid or the biggest
impact on society that ransom had
ransomware attacks had over the last
couple of years
well i think we're in the beginning of a
new age and i think you're completely
right and i'm
both interested and frightened to see
what what will happen uh but it sounds
like you're at the right place at the
right time and and really thank you for
taking the time to come and share your
story and your insights with me now
roman i want you to take me back a
little bit to your experience again back
to your childhood what what really
fascinates you as a kid and are you
always fascinated with financials even
in middle school let's say
as a kid the thing i cared most about is
science fiction books
and
more specifically uh the better science
fiction writers are the ones in my mind
who invent a new technology and then
explain the impact of that on society
and i think that what what we're seeing
happening with cyber is is a is a very
similar thing so that's gonna i've read
a lot that's all i did for many years
amazing and and what inspires you today
either professionally or personally
um
i i you know
trying not to be uh boring here but uh
our team our team at bay you know we
have an amazing team and one of their
main challenges is those are people who
come from very different disciplines and
try to american a traditional insurance
world with cyber security and data and
it's not a trivial marriage
it's very you know sometimes it's like
speaking foreign languages and i think
our team does an amazing job of
navigating that so that's always
inspiring to see very very cool and what
are three words you would use to
describe yourself
uh that's a tough one um i'll choose
thoughtful honest and ambitious as those
three points
thoughtful honest and ambitious woman
thank you very very much this was
wonderful to talk about this was so much
fun and enjoyable and insightful and
frightening all all at the same time
so i really wish you best of luck with
that bae and stay safe and stay healthy
thanks michael have a good one
thank you
you